all right every year more than 20,000
teenagers age out of the foster care
system and within just four years about
5,000 of them are homeless now the
federal government is stepping in to
help in an interview you'll see only on
CBS this morning Secretary of Housing
and Urban Development ben Carson spoke
with our national correspondent Jericka
Duncan about the innovative solution
Jericka good morning what did you learn
good morning well we learned that it
pays to advocate for yourself and you'll
know what I'm talking about here in a
second and all things that's right Gil
secretary Carson told us he's made it
his mission to move more Americans out
of public housing but after a group of
former foster kids came to see him
secretary Carson says he realized the
best move for them starts with being
able to have a place to call home
the one biggest thing that this has
given me is a sense of control over my
life control that was once a dream for
Denver area teen Heidi Seabrook going
from you know drugs to foster home to
group homes halfway houses and psych
wards in jail now the 18 year old has
the keys to a different future and this
her first own apartment through a new
federal housing initiative called foster
youth to independence I feel like this
is the first time my life that I have
the peace and the room to kind of
forgive myself to like grow a little bit
the fYI program puts rent within reach
and teach his job prep and life skills
to former foster children ages 18 to 24
there are so many people the solution
took a brain surgeon Ben Carson who
heads the federal agency overseeing
public housing in some ways this places
more people in public housing some
people think negatively about public
housing but public housing is actually
supposed to be a safety net the idea to
expand that safety net came from former
foster kids themselves they actually
took the initiative to come here and we
talk to them we listen to their stories
okay and that inspired the creation of
the program was that something that was
on your
before you know this really laser focus
that's on and you know people say it
takes the government a long time to do
anything but within four months program
was created and it's working
participants typically pay 30 percent of
their income towards rent the fYI
program covers the rest so far more than
two million dollars has gone to help out
nearly 250 former foster children when
they don't have that kind of support
they frequently fall into all kinds of
things you know drugs sex trade back in
Colorado Seabrook now sees a new future
who would think that I would go to
college it's not just like a drug addict
not just you know some kid in the system
I can really be like who I want and have
what every foster child really wants a
place they can call home you know
everything like is in my life I feel
like I allow it to be in my life and
everything that's in my house a lot of
screaming my house it's really giving me
a sense of peace that this is a really
safe place for me now Heidi has set her
sights on college she wants to become a
social worker to help at-risk teens like
herself and while the f.y.i program just
started secretary Carson said it's
already been big enough success that
he's adding almost a half million
dollars more to help more former foster
kids like Heidi find homes so obviously
two hundred and fifty right now with
this original program but you've got
twenty thousand so this is this is
helping but it obviously is a bigger
problem when you look at the big thing
for Heidi cuz she's been through so much
so much it's good to see that story have
a happy ending grant Within Reach
yep all right I love the interview with
Ben Carson where he says anyone okay
delivery the facial expression like okay
now we thank him for we do helping out
and absolutely because he we know he
doesn't talk very often it's an
important program and is making a
difference yeah
thank you mr. Carson thank you Jericho
you